Speaker 1: Well, we suspected it might happen
because of the increasingly uncontrolled spread of
the Delta variant and the resurgence in covid-19
cases, and it is happening, the CDC coming out
with new mass guidelines yesterday. We are going
backwards. The masks are going back on in many,
many places and seemingly overnight. I'm already
seeing more masks just walking around. And yes,
this is even for vaccinated people. We're going to
look at the new guidelines and I am going to sort
of couch it all in saying the situation has not
really changed that dramatically for vaccinated
people, although it has changed and it's
important to understand the ways in which it has.
But this is continuing to increasingly be a virus
that is being spread by unvaccinated people,
which is disproportionately seriously affecting
unvaccinated people. And that, for now,
appears to be the way it is going to continue.
But that doesn't mean, given what's going on,
that vaccinated people shouldn't take precautions
in certain places. So let's look at the new CDC
guidelines updated yesterday when you've
been fully vaccinated. OK, if you are fully
vaccinated, you can participate in many of the
activities that you did before the pandemic
to maximize protection from the Delta variant
and prevent possibly spreading it to others.
Wear a mask indoors in public. If you are in an
area of substantial or high transmission, that
is a major change. Whereas before the position
was if you're vaccinated, you don't really need
to wear a mask anywhere. The new guidelines
are if you're vaccinated, but you're indoors
in public, meaning not with five other people
whose vaccination status, you know, but if
you're in public, indoors and in an area of high
transmission, which you can look at, at a county
by county level, substantial or high transmission,
the new recommendation is to wear a mask for me.
What does that mean? Well, that means when I go to
the grocery store, the mask is going back on. It
goes on to say the new guidelines wearing a mask
is most important if you have a weakened immune
system or if because of your age or an underlying
medical condition, you are at increased risk for
severe disease, or if someone in your household
has a weakened immune system, is at increased
risk for severe disease or is unvaccinated,
if this applies to you or your household,
you might choose to wear a mask regardless
of the level of transmission in your area.
You should continue to wear a mask where required
by laws, rules, regulations or local guidance.
So this is a significant change and we are seeing
the spike. I mean, if you look at the US case
numbers, you will see that starting, oh, I don't
know, right around June 22nd about them. About
a month ago, after getting down below 10000 cases
per day, cases started to go up, up, up, including
even some sixty five thousand case days now up
to an average of about 57000 cases per day. Now,
what's the hope here? The hope is that much like
we are starting to see in some other countries,
for example, if you look at the U.K., which was
essentially one of the hubs of the Delta variant,
we have already apparently hit the peak of cases
in the U.K. that the peak in the U.K. of Delta
seems to have happened around July 22nd and
they are now down from about 46000 cases a day
to about thirty two thousand. That's a significant
reduction. The hope is that what is now a sort of
leveling out, as you can see over the last
few days, the cases aren't continuing to
increase in the U.S. They're sort of flattening
out. The hope would be we are now going to be
on the decline, but we don't know if we
are. And part of that depends, of course,
on taking precautions. So let's not go crazy
one way or the other. I think there's a lot of
hyperbole on both sides here. And I'm not playing
a both sides game. The people responsible for this
are overwhelmingly the unvaccinated people
and the people taking no precautions.
But the reactions have been sort of extreme on
both sides. There's one side that two months ago
said the pandemic is over. Many of these people
were never wearing masks. Many of these people are
still not vaccinated. And they're going back. And
and to quote Dr. Anthony Fauci, letting it rip,
that's an extreme reaction on one side because
it's clearly not over. On the other side are
the people who are seeing this and now saying we
are back to the pre vaccine, uncontrolled spread
era. The truth is that for the Delta variant, if
you're vaccinated, you're very well protected.
And that protection is bolstered by
people around you being vaccinated now,
just like with the flu, there are people who
are vaccinated who will who are otherwise
mostly healthy, who will get what's called a break
through case, and they will end up hospitalized
and a few of them are going to die. And that's a
terrible and tragic thing. But it's important to
remember that that also happens with the flu.
And we that doesn't mean we ignore this fact,
but it also doesn't mean that we all of a
sudden believe there's no protection. And
we're going back to the pre vaccine covid era.
The truth is that for the most part, you are
quite well protected. If you were vaccinated,
you are really unlikely to get very sick.
You are really unlikely to die. However, you could
spread it, you could spread it to someone who is
in a more compromised position. And although
that's the situation with the Delta variant,
the more people remain unvaccinated in the more
the spread continues. The next variant could be
more deadly. The next variant could be even
more transmissible. And as we've said before,
imagine if this had an eight percent mortality
rate or a 10 percent mortality rate. If
I don't know that people are looking to read
about this type of stuff right now, I don't know.
People are looking for this type of fiction. But
I recently read Lawrence Wright's pandemic novel,
I believe is called The End of October, where
it's a very similar situation to the one we have,
except it's like a 10 percent death rate instead
of up zero point eight percent death rate or
whatever. We believe the real infection fatality
rate to be, that is a dramatically different
situation. The more we don't get vaccinated and
the more this continues to spread, it increases
the chances of such a variant developing in the
future. So these are the rules at this point in
time. People asking me if I'm if I'm canceling my
upcoming travel. I'm not. And the reason I'm not
is this situation of different pops and spreads,
particularly among the unvaccinated, is likely to
continue for a couple of years. And so if I'm not
willing to travel now, I probably shouldn't travel
for years. And I've made the decision in speaking
with friends who are doctors and others that right
now, based on when I got vaccinated and based
on this particular variant and based on the fact
that I'll be wearing a mask everywhere that it's
recommended, I don't see a particular reason to
cancel that trip now. But a lot of the questions
are where are you going and what is your health
status, et cetera. One example we're talking on
the bonus show today, Nevada or Nevada is going
fully mask back on and people are being advised to
avoid Las Vegas. The level of uncontrolled spread
in Las Vegas is so high, the case positivity
rate is so high that that's a point where people
are being told, just don't go there and I don't
plan to. So that's that's the situation there.